[Music]
in locked up abroad news submitted by
Fat Joe I'm not fat lean back oh that's
[ __ ] or a shoe that's still a dope
song if you want to do something lean
back lean down lean back
yes a British woman is detained in Egypt
after carrying 300 pain pills for her
husband 300 but what is he doing or what
is he going through the he knees 300
pain pills Paul he's traveling with his
wife selling drugs if you gotta beat
them to the joke now they can't say [ __ ]
anymore
I've never make jokes about - moment of
silence yeah I don't know what happened
it's true because it was so much truth
in it yeah I was basking in my moment
prior to that comment so I didn't even
hear what you said okay that song is so
good right the music video was the jam
but take it away Tiffany yeah so this
woman her name is Laura Plummer she's
she is a porn star different type of
song pause it go hug your pipe you talk
ya know it was like in a compilation and
then they were like and then it's like
yeah right there and then it's like with
music like it sounds like EDM with house
music mix cuz there's a song like that
yeah oh yeah there's mony
there's song like that it'd be weird if
it on Spotify looking for porn me yeah I
was driving then yeah that's where that
music would probably do it it's not a
good I was like is that the actual girl
or is in the song it was in the song oh
I know that song vanity 6 nasty girl I
was in the car with my mom and then that
song was playing and at the very end
there's the there's the song at the very
end that girls moan II know she sounds
like [ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me today she
speaks at accents all day yes dear
can we back up real quick you covered
the collar dear yes they're switching
places no even candies like that you
speak like that
she'll unclog her drains her own drains
yeah she was stopped at the airport by
airport security and they found 300 pain
pills on her that make sense there they
were
tramadol pills yup trying to look at is
she her her elbow she was clearly
something there's some mixed reports
here because there's one report coming
out saying that her man is her boyfriend
and that he already has a wife and a
child and then there's this other report
saying that they are legally married
yeah so whatever the relationship is his
name is Omar kibou and he's 31 years old
and so Laura was claiming that Lucy oh
yeah she's 33 because I immediately
thought they were senior citizens
because of the painkillers
yeah that's why I thought too yeah so
Laura 300 pills yeah nothing [ __ ] you
see how many pills my grandma had to
take before she died but you have to
take like my grandma took the end
there's like my crap you know what you
[ __ ] like back in the day when you
show your family pictures and you go Shh
yeah my grandma had a [ __ ] pill
pocketing full of those per day it was
like AM 7:00 a.m. a.m. a.m. 12:00 at
3:00 p.m. 5:00 here whatever do it it's
crazy though old people be taking
crazy-ass pills now I understand why you
have the Monday to day when they thought
they'd find a better day
you know because you can't keep track of
that exactly because there's like eight
pills in that [ __ ] dude I will probably
just die so this is Laura and Omar and
so they're vacationing in Egypt right so
she was the Egyptian lavas the initial
report that came out in it
yet for the initial report that came out
was that this was her boyfriend but that
they lived together and immediately
after she got arrested a couple days
later he scheduled his flight back home
and he just abandoned her even though
she was claiming like these pills are
for him because he got in a car accident
two years ago and he was prescribed for
his back pain well the initial report
here so it looked like really shady on
the guy I was immediately thinking those
are his pills he's a drug dealer he's
trying to take them into I don't know
he's just making my own assumptions cuz
a lot of people were also saying similar
things and then later on it came out
that oh and so I forgot to mention the
main thing she was facing death like the
death penalty they're gonna put her to
sarcophaguses [ __ ] now she was facing
either 25 years in prison or death
penalty smuggling smuggling a million
drugs if they found that she took those
pills into the country for the intent to
sell them to other people then that's
what she's facing my death penalty or
you know wasn't stuffed up her vagina
was just on a Ledge you say vagina
vagina vagina vagina vagina vagina huh
[Music]
I'm not sure exactly where is just say
that she was carrying that imagination
will just say vagina Virgina
I thought her butthole Oh chicken
pancakes no me neither me neither
I just take the [ __ ] pain man when I
got my boobies done I didn't do I like
Mike wow you're a trooper no no wait up
don't give me that much credit it was in
the beginning but then after that
anything okay so I'm not too bright I
like Vicodin girl yeah what the hell
looks like like a retired Jersey Shore
number looks like hey I feel like I
could take his this picture I'll put a
white coat on him and he's like the fake
laboratory technician in the commercial
or something yeah yeah
and this is Lara with her father let's
see what Lauren's a month already in oh
yeah a whole month what is that like how
you do fix everywhere
I don't know but her family was saying
that they were really concerned over her
mental state because she was just saying
like she can't take it and dirty it's
only been a month and it was just drama
right so then they were saying even if
they prove that she took those pills
into the country for him that they can
provide like medical documentation and
showing like it was for that reason she
still faces seven years in prison so
right now she's like that's not fair
that's [ __ ] crazy you binge on Bonnie
wouldn't do that
yeah and so now like the most recent
report that's coming out of this story
is that laura has been able to provide
evidence that she did take those pills
for the person husband so now we're just
gonna wait to see if that's enough to
let her out but 300 I know I think oh
you know what they did grab the bollocks
do it in No I looked it up I looked at
that drug three hundred you get like six
would be three bottles you're so busy
you look like that how many you have to
take a day and how long are the yeah if
they're there for like six months or
like you don't know yeah if you gotta
take like six a day you know depends on
how many you have to take a day or each
time killers make you feel so weird
I don't like it dude I mean on the
bottle though isn't it written like from
dr. Dave to ally booboo peekaboo mr.
Omar peekaboo or maybe she just had it
in a ziploc kaboom oh she took it out of
the original bottle what if she was the
drug lord have you guys ever taken we
could on yeah yes mesh it crazy do you
know I was nursing so I was like like
yeah he was that's right like I was
still in pain but I stopped taking the
pills cuz I saw him be all like really
loopy I think I did too many drugs
because I took vicodin and they're like
because I had my wisdom teeth removed so
I didn't take it illegally and then
they're like you shouldn't drive but I
did and I felt floaty what do they give
you when they get the eye surgery you
give I can if I get it no I got LASIK
yeah if you think if they give you some
sort of IQ Dennard or oxy caught on one
of those to my it was all right it's not
too crazy Muriel was on some home
whenever they gave her that [ __ ] was
Lou pious [ __ ] she couldn't she couldn't
lift her feet so she's just walking
around the hall are you doing they get
your drug tolerance did you taking mad
drugs and it's kind of like nothing is
so relaxing I was all over the place she
was eating this dry ass muffin like it
was the most delicious thing she's
already know she's like this is all good
as she's talking it's like sucking all
the we're trying to get to the [ __ ]
part I would record it cuz I'll actually
getting a little manager know cuz I
tried I was like leave right she's like
I know where to go I know where to go I
was like no the the [ __ ] car is
downstairs right but she keeps going up
higher and we go all the way to the roof
to that point and we got to a certain
floor I like that's the roof she goes no
it's not and then she goes out if the
wrong [ __ ] oh my god the funny thing is
you're trying to lodge it like be
reasonable what could have been sit
together because she was gone
yeah but they gave her the the thing
while she was there sitting on the the
armchair while she was saying they gave
her some water and they gave him the
Viking or whatever some [ __ ] so she was
all over the place I don't know sleeping
FEMA it's like to calm you down I'm like
I'm not perfect whatever they gave me I
had to take two of them cuz one of them
didn't do enough and I could feel my
eyes burning and so my brother was like
y'all just take another one else it's
not gonna work he's I just take it I
took it
thirty seconds later Wow dead my brother
thought I'd died cuz he why did he set
you the pill words that I had the first
one
yeah the second one just overdid it and
so I guess he went to the bathroom and
he went the cup check up Bobby I knocked
out by the whole time he was at the
prison he came back I used to do that
one they should I should know it ecstasy
cuz you know like ecstasy like it you
takes like 30 minutes to 45 minutes to
kick in so I was like oh I'm a [ __ ]
stack this [ __ ] where I take one
now and exactly in 30 to 45 minutes I
take the second one so that way when it
right when I feel it then the next one
not coming on a field both peaks at the
same time so what happened and then you
get you build up your talent you start
taking eight pills a night I don't
condone drug you'll see used to speak I
used to chew on the ecstasy pill in my
mouth and then dissolve it so it will
hit me harder it does it does [ __ ] where
you go you drink the water and in your
life any pills cuz pills just but we but
you shouldn't do it it's horrible but
you know the song when it goes to
dudududududu did you get it like the
build-up like you feel the build-up like
harder drugs are horrible but [ __ ]
bad you might die we're talking about
like 10 years ago
[Music]
[Music]